everyone always says that being in your
20s is the best it's the best time of
your life and you this is the part where
you get to live and make mistakes and I
always question like why is it that I
put so much pressure on myself to be
somewhere at a certain age like why
won't I be able to find My Success at 35
or 40 why do I have to feel like by the
time I'm 30 I need to be financially
secure for the rest of my life have a
routine down have a full-blown business
cuz I think it is important to have
these conversations in a way I'm hoping
it'll light a fire under my ass and just
throw myself into it I'm hoping that the
struggle will become my strength all of
those times that I felt alone and I was
forced to read and I was like how am I
ever going to get out of this it
developed into what I'm passionate today
like with writing it's kind of just
having to remind yourself like everyone
is in the same boat as you everyone is
trying to figure it out everyone's
trying to find their partner everyone's
trying to figure out their career it
doesn't work overnight